good morning first and foremost really
quickly just want to create some context
how many people in this auditorium have
no idea who I am raise your hands that
[ __ ] hurts actually if we can keep
the lights on that be amazing I'd rather
see the faces I figured that was the
case so I'm gonna take a few minutes to
give you context of where I come from
and then we can go into the the spiel
and then I guess we'll do some Q&A I was
born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union
I came to America when I was three years
old and I was extremely poor as you
could imagine my family lived in a
studio apartment in Queens New York with
uh with eight family members my dad got
a job at a liquor store getting paid two
dollars an hour and that's where our
American dream started he eventually
saved up all his money over five years
and bought a small liquor store in New
Jersey which is where we moved where I
grew up I was always a business kid
salesman selling lemonade baseball cards
whatever I could do to make money when I
was 14 my dad dragged me into the liquor
store that he owned and I went from
making $1,000 a weekend selling baseball
cards to making two bucks an hour
bagging ice for 15 hours a day so went
from a thousand a day to $30 a day I
call those the [ __ ] years somewhere
around 16 17 I fell in love with the
idea of wine and more importantly
collecting wine at this point to take it
a step back and want everybody
understand by the time I decided I
wanted to run my dad's business I I was
probably 18 or 19 years old I had never
even owned a computer in my life I have
probably spent less than five hours of
my entire life at 18 years old in front
of a computer I'm a little bit older
than some peeps in this room and so
that's just the way it was I mean
there's a lot of people in this room
that don't remember the world
pre-internet but it existed and so
and so you know I I thought that I was
gonna open up a hundred liquor stores a
hundred wine stores across America you
know one day sell it and buy the New
York Jets which is an American football
team which is my my business and life
goals still to this day in 1994 I went
to college and I was in my dorm room
playing Madden 94 on on Sega Genesis and
my friend ran in and he said you have to
come and see this and so after a couple
of uh after I finished my game I went
into my friend's dorm room and him and
seven of my friends were sitting in
front of a computer and it was the first
time that I had ever heard couch which
is old-school dial-up internet and my
friends stood in from this computer and
my friend Joe looked at me and he said
the words that changed my life forever
he stood him from this computer I had
never seen the internet before I said
these profound words is this the
information superhighway you know that's
what we called it then and he looked at
me and he said yeah he goes and these
are the words that changed my life he's
in front of a computer he looks at me
and he says we can get chicks on this
thing
and so we proceeded to spend seven hours
on AOL talking to what we think was
girls somewhere about five minutes into
this process i sat there again this was
old school like there was a guy in front
of a computer and seven people like
hanging over it I stood there and about
five or six minutes and - ever seeing
the Internet I said holy crap I think I
can sell [ __ ] on this and I decided by
that night that I no longer needed to
open a thousand liquor stores that I was
going to figure this thing out there was
something here by that summer in 1996
about a year later excuse me and into
that summer in 1996 I launched
winelibrary.com which was the second
ecommerce wine business in the United
States in the the site cost me $15,000
to build in 1996 in the first year of
operations the entire site sold $800
worth of wine that's exactly right
I don't know how many of you have a
Soviet father but Sasha was not happy
with that ROI what was interesting was
that nobody was committed to it I was
still somewhat in school I still had no
[ __ ] idea what to do with websites
and most people were not comfortable
with putting their credit card into a
computer back then what's interesting to
me and what I want to spend the rest of
my time talking about is how did I go
from 1996 that site doing eight hundred
and fifty dollars in sales to the fact
that when I did take over my dad's wine
business in 1998 it was a three million
dollar business and in a five-year
window from 98 to 2003 I grew that
business from a three to a sixty million
dollar business I did it with all the
tactics and skillsets that most of this
room has in 1998 most people weren't
thinking about you know email marketing
they definitely weren't thinking about
Adwords or banner retargeting or all the
quantum stuff that many people think
about here look I wasn't really that
kind of character I think I'm more quant
to spend most of my time in this talk
though about is as I got ready for this
conference and I started understanding
who's in the audience and I followed the
hashtag and tried to really bring value
here today the thing that I want people
to understand is there's two core words
that I spend a lot of time thinking
about right now the new thing that I'm
spending most of my time on is something
that I call the attention graph right at
the end of the day we're all battling to
create a conversion to sell something
whether you're hardcore DR and math and
quant or if you're trying to build a
brand and play the long game a lot of
people in this room as I was digging
down the rabbit hole on my flight and
looking at what you did for a living
there's a lot of people in this room
that have really figured out conversion
right really understand the value of the
current state of the internet but the
thing that I spend almost all of my time
on is lifetime value right because the
thing that's happening right now with my
smartest math driven quant friends is
there's a disrespect to what happens to
create an actual brand or business for
the long term if this was just a math
game Groupon and LivingSocial and Zynga
would have won this a long time again
though so what I'm really trying to
figure out is if people are really
understanding the mix of the two and the
value my friends is in the attention
graph let me explain I have 1.2 million
followers on Twitter that's in 2015 in
February in 2007 when I had a hundred
thousand followers on Twitter I was
getting dramatically more conversion
because the supply of noise was so
different we live in a world where I
know more than anything guys let me take
a step back you don't mind what let me
just take a step back more than I know
that the Sun will come up tomorrow I
know one thing
marketers ruin everything
and I need everybody to understand that
how many people here have done email
marketing in their career have done
email marketing understanding raising
high get hit with me I want to see this
perfect in 1997 I had a 240,000 person
wine email list that had ninety 1.1
percent open rates Thank You Germany
have a good night and I and and this is
why this is a fun room for me because I
know who's in this room seventy-three
percent click-through ratio to the
product or the Buy button 1997 now I'm
sure all of you know that those numbers
are not going to be touched you know why
in 1997 in America marketers hadn't
[ __ ] up email yet right at that point
when you got it you read everything for
all the old-school people here in 94 95
we read every [ __ ] word of every
email that's right and when Google
AdWords came out I bought the word wine
on Google AdWords the day Google AdWords
came out for five cents and owned it for
nine and a half months before anybody
bid me up that's how you win that's the
arbitrage we're sitting in a room here
right now we're a far majority of people
don't understand the arbitrage value
that's going on right now they
understand the tried and true of SCM or
banner retargeting or buying on the
exchange they understand those things
because they've been established but it
is stunning to me how many people are
disrespecting Facebook dark posts
unpublished post and retargeting right
now in a world where I've seen bigger D
our conversion rates through that
channel that I've seen since the
beginning of Google AdWords as the best
conversion funnel I've ever seen yet
most people are struggling with it
because the far majority of the skilled
practitioner in this room understand dr
and conversion but they understand it
more in a banner and google world not in
a facebook world that is completely
reliant on the creative right because
understand one thing right this second
facebook is sitting
on the biggest data and most accurate
data set we've seen ever it is stunning
how far down the rabbit hole and how
much we can use our other data and
implement it and create look like
audiences and create conversion yet even
though for the last 20 months the best
practitioners have been exposing this
the market is still not aware so I can
still drive two and three and four
dollars CPMs to websites right now off
of Facebook but they were a dollar fifty
five minutes ago and they're gonna be
$11 CPMs in five minutes as the market
corrects see the game we need to keep
playing and the reason that I was able
to build that business and the reason
that I've been able to continue what
I've done and the reason I invested back
in 2006 and 78 and things like Twitter
and Facebook and Tumblr is that it's
just always the same old game my friends
arbitrage right it's the same old game
where is the value while the rest of the
market doesn't understand it you can
play catch-up or you can be a leader the
leader has the opportunity of getting
dramatically bigger ROI in the short
term but the problem is you have to be
willing to take the risk you can't wait
for the white papers to come out to tell
you how to do it
you can't wait and so I implore a lot of
you in this room to really take a step
back and really think about what's going
on because what is happening right in
front of all of our eyes right now is we
are living through this single biggest
culture shift of our time this internet
thing is grossly underrated by every
single person in this room the rock star
sitting here me included this is only a
20 year phenomenon the Internet as we
know it for the consumer is a 20 year
thing I know there's some nerd in the
back and ii actually garyun in 1950s i
know [ __ ] nerd but i mean normal
people 20 years 20 years how many people
in this room remember the world
pre-internet raise your hands I mean
it's sure does does anybody understand
what's happening here it's just
started and people think it's over I
remember being at a conference in like a
Facebook and Twitter one it's over right
in the 36 months since the [ __ ] idiot
said it was over Instagram Pinterest
snapchat it's just started everything we
talked about everything every person in
this room talks about didn't exist ten
years ago
maybe twelve twelve years ago twelve
none of this [ __ ] existed so I implore
everybody to understand a couple things
one if you're not thinking about
lifetime value your play only lasts for
so long and so while you're converting
or doing whatever you're doing and and
and and more importantly actually I'm
gonna take another step back marketers
brand people ad tech people please can
we start making the conversation about
depth versus with like I'm so tired of
how many [ __ ] impressions or
awareness this is created I don't know
about you guys but like when I was
building my wine business there was no
justification to Sasha that a lot of
[ __ ] people heard about it he was
very simple eyes like how many bottles
of Pinot Noir did it sell right super
simple and so what's happening in the
marketing world is we're scoring for the
sake of awareness and we're not
understanding what it's doing for sales
on the flip side on the flip side for a
lot of people in this room we need to
start debating what's the emotional
connection what brand are we actually
building how is it not just quant how
are we building something that lasts
when our arbitrage or our cuantas n't
work anymore right so look here's the
world I live in right now if you're in
this room and you're trying to sell
stuff and you haven't realized that on
an everyday basis Instagram continues to
grow and become the leading social
network you're not living in 2015 we're
watching it completely sweep and look I
did as much homework as I could on
what's happening in the German market
the growth is there but just to give you
an insight I'm sure this is at some
level the rationale why to bring
American speakers to this conference
look I have a lot of friends in Europe
and I always tell them
and as as you heard earlier being born
in Europe I'm I'm completely fascinated
by the notion of how you can see trends
happen in the US market and then take
advantage of that to understand one
thing no matter where you live so many
of the human behaviors are similar
obviously there's cultural differences
obviously hey look I come from a place
where people want to keep secrets
because you want to be safe but the
bottom line is so many things translate
so please pay attention to the fact that
Instagram is growing at a rapid pace but
for a majority of this room
you don't like Instagram do you because
on the post level there is no link out
to quantify your conversion right
there's no link out to drive your sale
yet we disrespect the attention graph
that at the end of the day the consumer
is spending an enormous amount of time
actually consuming their photos on
Instagram and though I have only 55 or
60 thousand followers on Instagram I'm
able to drive a lot more awareness and
results because by owning a wine shop by
owning my data on how I sell books by
owning all the funnel and understanding
all the way through though I can't
quantify against the link because that's
not how Instagram works I can isolate
tests very easy and understand I am
creating my conversion funnel because it
all comes down to attention attention is
what I give a [ __ ] about I run a company
called vaynermedia right now we have
fortune 500 companies you know Unilever
and Pepsi and Toyota big big brands
Michael you know it's insane my it's
insane what's going on with television
advertising in the US an 80 billion
dollar industry and all we're trying to
do look no matter what you do in this
room no matter what you do every person
in this room has one job the job is to
grab somebody's attention and then tell
them your story and then sell them your
[ __ ] whether you're trying to raise
money for your school or sell sneakers
or whatever you're trying to do that is
your job you need somebody's attention
and then you get a chance to tell them
your story and the fact that matter is
what's really interesting to me is that
people are misunderstanding how
quickly the attention is fleeting away
from things just now people are sitting
in a conference room around the world
saying we should really get serious
about our Twitter strategy right I mean
that's happening that's real talk
meanwhile you just heard what's happened
to my interest graph or attention graph
from 2007 to 2015
bigger results at a hundred thousand
followers than one-point-two because the
supply and demand of how many tweets and
how much one can pay attention to so
right now I am spending an ungodly
amount of time on Instagram and snapchat
and in 36 months the rest of the US
market will say uh let's start getting
serious about these things and then I'll
be focusing on Yik yak or something else
that has emerged because the opening
moments are always the most valuable
then you hit critical mass you get value
out of that and then it starts sloping
on the other end and so that is the
rinse and repeat of marketing always and
forever from radio to television to
cable television to the Internet to web
102 web 200 to social media it's the
same old game over and over and over
again and the winners in this game over
and over again are not scared to waste
their time I spent 41 sleepless nights
two years ago trying to figure out
Socialcam Socialcam was gonna be the
next big thing it exploded in five
minutes in the US because Facebook gave
it a disproportionate advantage in the
newsfeed when it first came out and
everybody was on it and I didn't sleep
for [ __ ] the big thing that I'm proud of
with myself is when I see something and
I believe in it I completely shut down
go into a cave and figure it the [ __ ]
out right and what that means for me cuz
I worked 15 hours a day is 11 p.m. to
4:00 in the morning and so I spent a
month from 11 p.m. to 4:00 in the
morning figuring Socialcam out and then
it was dead right dead and a lot of my
buddies who know this is my thesis they
got a real kick out of that because they
were sick of me talking about how I won
on Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr but
this time they got to stick it to me and
they did and I wasted my time
however only nine and a half months
later something came out called
mine and all the things I learned about
the way the consumers engaged but
Socialcam became enormous IP for me on
how to figure out how people used vine
and even though vine ironically is
starting to slow down and lose its
luster it had an 18 month run where
there was a lot of value I did start a
agency that represented all the vine and
snapchat stars with a guy by the name of
Jerome Jarre and built an enormous
Liebig ten million dollar business in 24
months all on the IP that I learned
because the truth is the psychology of
the user is always the same the
platforms may change but the behavior is
similar and that's what we need to
figure out back to TV
80 million billion dollars spent how
many people in this room besides live
sports
now watch TV on their time not what it
airs but you watch it on Netflix or HBO
GO or DVR PVR whatever you guys got what
do you call it DVR what do you call it
DVD great how many people watch their
favorite TV shows not what it actually
ears but when you want to watch it raise
your hands
Oh weird everybody and how many of you
in the last year every time you get a
chance
fast-forward every single commercial
raise your hands yeah and so this is
what's happening my friends 80 billions
dollars spent to try to tell stories to
a world where we all run away from it
how many people here can't wait to open
their cell phone and click the pop-up
banner ad that takes over the page they
want that's what I figured
yet plenty of people here give
recommendations to use it my friends
it's cops and robbers mouse and cat we
as consumers don't want to be bothered
we don't want to be interrupted
the reason Facebook has worked so well
is because as the world's gone mobile
and the ads are natively in the feed
they're not disrupting us from what we
actually want to do right I for example
will never buy a Samsung item again you
know why because this is how marketing
works in 2015
last year the New York Jets my favorite
football team we're gonna trade a player
so every day I was going to espn.com on
my phone in between every meeting just
to make sure I didn't miss it
of course I had all the updates and
followed all the things but I just did
not want to miss it so 20 times a day I
would go to espn.com every single time
that I did a big fat banner popped up
for Samsung write all of them and as you
guys know the banners on cellphones
they're small and the X even smaller and
our thumb even bigger right so eight out
of the 20 times when I went to exit out
so I could go to where I really wanted
to go
I missed the X and I clicked the Samsung
banner back home at agencyland
and samsung land and quant guy'll and
they're like look at this impressions
look at these 20 impressions he clicked
it eight time that's an incredible click
the ratio alright so back home the math
looks phenomenal right back home the
click through ratio is through the
[ __ ] roof but in reality I called my
wife the eighth time and I said Lizzy
you listen to me this family until I'm
dead will never buy a [ __ ] Samsung
item again
we all know it right we all know it and
I tweeted out to my million 0.2
followers 18 times
[ __ ] you Samsung that's okay if only a
couple thousand saw it back to the
problem but then I took a selfie on
Instagram and said [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
Samsung more people saw it and I've gone
on for the last 15 months to conferences
and telling the story - [ __ ] you Samsung
and my hope is that two or three of you
were affected deeply by this and never
buy another Samsung item what that means
is the ROI on that 50 percent
click-through is horrible and that's how
it works isn't it
right there is so much wrong data right
there's so much wrong big data we talk
about it we look at it but the problem
is we just have a whole lot of marketers
who just like to market and the problem
is we just have a whole lot of math guys
and gals who just like the math of it
but at the end of the day aren't we
really all just sitting here talking
about actual business like how the [ __ ]
do I sell this sneaker huh how do I sell
this sneaker I sell it by many different
ways and sure I can have somebody go to
my website look at this sneaker cookie
the [ __ ] out of him follow him around
the internet until he [ __ ] gives up
and buys him I can do that and I like
that that's one way to do it but that
can't be the only way to do it because
that person might be after a 19 time
that he goes on a website and sees
another banner for this sneaker that
person might turn it into Samsung right
we have to do other things plus more
importantly more importantly we live in
a world now of an alternative listen I
have no vested interest in Facebook
doing great or not great I fully believe
that I will be making fun of Facebook
dark posts ads in three to four years
when the ROI swing goes the other
direction but I implore everybody to at
least understand the psychology of why
it works it works because it's native in
the stream it works because it's a mix
of the two groups of people that are in
this room the quant
and the qua right
it's targeted as [ __ ] but you still need
to put the right video in the picture
and the right copy and the right
creative to hit them in the ear it's
always the brain and the heart it's
always the brain and the heart and way
too many people are either on team brain
or team heart and you need to smash them
together and when you find platforms
that allow you to do both Allah what
Facebook does right now you've got a
very special moment and I'm sure that
Instagram or snapchat or Yik yak or
whatever else comes out in the future
will pay attention to the value prop
here and it is a major value prop and so
if I can get anybody here especially on
the quant banner retargeting math side
to please take a deeper look into that
world you will see humongous dividends
but please go into that world with much
bigger eyes to recognize you need to
respect the creative because the
creative is always the variable to the
conversion alright so there's that what
else can I do in my nine minutes a
couple other things I want to talk to
you about why did I hate Samsung it's
something I want you guys to spend a lot
of time on and ironically the answer is
time I invested in uber pretty early on
I missed the first round or two which
was a huge mistake on my part because I
loved Travis but then I finally invested
in it and I'm still gonna do great and
I'm excited about it but why did I
ultimately make the plunge
after I passed on it to invest it was
because my brother who took the first
uber ride in New York which I think is
amazingly interesting we I remember us
thinking about how would ever work in
New York in a world where we have the
best transportation system in the world
and what I realized a couple months in
was oh my god
uber doesn't sell transportation uber
sells time the reason I take an uber is
because I'm guaranteed it's gonna be
there and I'm taking away the risk of
waiting three or four minutes for a cab
uber sells time the reason I was pissed
at Samsung was because every time I
clicked that banner it took me another
hundreds of a second to exit out the
website and go back to where I wanted
and that hundreds of a second really
matters to me if you take a step back
with me my friends right now and journey
with me I promise you you outside of the
health and well-being of the people
you love the most and second your money
the thing that you value the most in the
world is time think about the last time
that your phone or your laptop where the
internet was a couple of a hundred
seconds slower than normal
think about how pissed you were right
it's crazy how these seconds have become
so valuable in a world where we're
getting pounded all the time where every
minute counts how many people in this
room is back to the old-school
pre-internet I mean I grew up
pre-internet I was at I I worked before
the internet completely took over how
many people here remember when you work
nine to five nine two six nine to seven
that that was it that the day was over
remember that world that world doesn't
exist anymore you're getting pounded
24/7 365 and so what's happened in the
world that's become so intense is we
value time so much more and so why am I
telling you this I'm telling you this
because that's why my open rates on
email have gone down from ninety-one
percent to thirty five percent it's why
my tweets are being engaged with as much
it's the supply and demand of attention
and the core the core pillar of that is
your time so we as marketers as business
people as who we are in the world we
need to figure out when we're doing
executions are we actually respecting
the person on the other side's time are
we actually caring about that at all
because every second that goes by that
is becoming a bigger and bigger
importance and value prop to the end
consumer and so many of our tactics
completely disrespect that and it's
something that I want a lot of people to
think about so what else outdoor media I
know this doesn't sit for a lot of
people in this room but it's a perfect
example for me of behavior changes
because we're living through the biggest
culture shift of our time billboards
multi-billion dollar industry around the
world do me a favor when you leave this
conference if you happen to be driving
in the next couple of months look around
I promise you there's not a single
person that's a passenger in a car
anymore that is not looking down at
their phone so how can the ROI of a
billboard be as valuable as it used to
be when the attention is going in the
other direction because of the
technology shifts we're living through
as a matter of fact do me a real big
favor when you're driving make sure you
look over I promise you another thing
forget about the passenger three out of
every five of the drivers they're also
looking at their phone so my friends
people are looking at billboards anymore
they're not even looking at the [ __ ]
road
the average 27 year old in a recent
survey could not recall anything on the
right side of a website including the
most important information why that's
where banners have lived for so long and
literally it has become a blind spot to
the end consumer a literal blind spot on
the screen because we grew and the 27
year old grew up with Facebook 3 desktop
when it was there and could not recall
anything including the most important
information at scale tens of thousands
of people surveyed could not recall the
right side of a website because that is
the blind spot
arbitrage ROI I want to talk to you
about another sector that is becoming
massively important and is being
disrespected and has a 24 to 36 month
window for you to get a bigger return on
your investment I call it micro
celebrity I don't mean people with a
million or two million followers I mean
the long tail of influence I have seen
enormous conversion rates great brand
building sales the [ __ ] we should all
care about by engaging people that have
five hundred nine hundred thirty seven
thirteen thousand and one followers
especially when you do it on Instagram
I've seen very little on Twitter but on
Instagram completely over the top back
to the point of attention and so I
highly recommend people in this room
that are trying to create ROI and
understand sell brand market for you to
start going down a path there's a
company I'm desperately trying to invest
in right now I think I'm gonna get it
otherwise I wouldn't say it out loud
it's a company called Co everywhere you
may want to check it out they're using
Instagram
API you can literally circle a location
on a map and I'll show you the most
influential people in that area on
Instagram using instagrams new open API
of location it has been stunning to me
how you can find the most popular girl
in high schools give her a free t-shirt
and get an enormous ROI on your campaign
even if that free t-shirt is 50 bucks
even if they're that free t-shirt is
five hundred dollars for a lot of people
in this room that rely completely on
math and the quant and the ads you'd be
stunned how the math works out on an
acquisition that looks like that and
sure I know a lot of people are sitting
here and thinking it's not scalable but
let me promise you something my friends
the best stuff the stuff that sells the
most is always scaling the unscalable if
it's scalable everybody else is doing it
and that ruins the supply and demand of
attention and so we're living in
interesting times it's 2015 how many
people in this room including when
they're sleeping are never arms-length
away from the phone raise your hands
raise it high look at this I mean this
[ __ ] is crack cocaine right I mean and
this starts the process if you really
understand it that gets really
interesting which is it starts here and
eventually it's gonna I think it's gonna
be here an invention it's gonna be here
and look I'm as pissed as anybody that
we're gonna be [ __ ] robots but it's
gonna happen right and what you need to
understand about this is why and how
come and what's really important about
that it's the attention right it's
always the attention if all of our eyes
and ears are here and you're not
thinking mobile furred guys if you're
not thinking mobile first guys if you
have websites that you give a [ __ ] about
that are not mobile-friendly that are
not mobile native in 2015 you're just
not living in the world that we actually
live in right you're just you're just
not and look
I probably have two or three websites
that aren't mobile friendly right like
like I know we all do it but that is
another call to action from this talk
we've got to fix that this is absolutely
the entire market the whole thing and
then let's think about why Google is
nervous because if you think about it
right now if you take a step back this
has been fun to do in crowds especially
educated crowds like this this is
stunning it is fascinating how much less
I actually search on Google on my phone
versus the way I did it on my desktop
the behavior is so different isn't it
and that we have to learn from we have
to learn from that behavior we have to
understand how to be mobile first we
have to understand that we're just
starting I saw an end with this and then
we'll go into Q&A just saw startup
because I do a lot of investing in the
US
they've got smart pants right so we all
know about smart phones right are you
Germany ready for smart pants let me
tell you what your smart pants do your
smart pants talk to your phone let me
paint you picture of what's going on in
the US and across the world which is I
think everybody here can agree that
within the next half decade to a decade
all of us are paying for everything with
this right this is how you pay now let
me talk to you about how your smart
pants talk to your smartphone so you put
is that is that how you guys do it here
oh it's you doing it just give me a
dress my job give me two minutes do
please I promise okay thank you
all right try your best ready smart
pants you put on your [ __ ] smart
pants right in Germany like now you give
a talk you go to the airport right after
that's just like I do and I try to go
eat something I am supposed to be
putting on a little less weight I've
been working out I run to Burger King I
want to buy some food I say give me a
whopper and some fries great I order it
659 great I take out my phone I go to
pay for it
declined and my phone says from my smart
pants on attack say eat a salad fat ass
everything everything in our lives over
the next two three decades
we'll be smart our wine glass will tell
us to drink the wine because it's
getting warm our pants will tell us to
eat a salad we have to understand in a
connected fast-paced world attention is
the only asset and if we as marketers
continue to disrespect the consumer and
continue to force them to click our
buttons and only rely on the math and
make us feel good and not recognize that
we're hurting our brands not helping
over the long term we will lose and I
implore you not to lose thank you